and the Oscar goes to Anthony Hopkins
[Music]
[Applause]
before I said I want to say hello to my
mother
she's in Wales watching this on
television
uh with Eve and Jean and Jill and Tony
my father died 11 years ago tonight so
maybe he had something to do with this
as well I don't know but I want to say
thank you to the academy for your
tremendous generosity
to my friend Bob Palmer my friend
publishes my dear beloved wife
Jenny and I have many people to thank
here in Los Angeles who
over the years have given me tremendous
support without
whose help I wouldn't be here I know
and I am
greatly honored and tremendously moved
and I
God bless you all thank you very much
[Applause]